frédéric voyons les chiffres en 2015
quels sont les montants que l'on reçoit
du fédéral et du provincial alors ça
dépend évidemment de votre salaire et de
la durée de vie active mais la
prestation annuelle moyenne à c6900
dollars pour les canadiens avec donc
c'est à peu près 5 175 par mois si vous
aller jusqu'au maximum évidemment des
cotisations la c12 1800 $ par année donc
1065 par mois ce qui est pas forcément
énorme ça c'est si vous habitez au
canada si vous habitez au québec là vous
ne recevez pas ça vous allez recevoir la
fameuse rentes du québec puisque le
québec est la seule province au canada
qui a décidé de faire la propre
administration donc çà çà çà fêtait
justement ses 50 ans cette année donc il
ya 65 ans que la régie des rentes du
québec a été lancée pour les montants
qui vous sont offertes donc chaque année
après votre très très bien c'est
sensiblement la même chose que le
fédéral c'est à dire jusqu'à un maximum
de douze mille 800 $ par année
bon l'ontario vient de lancer son propre
régime de retraite obligatoire là pour
les employés qui n'ont pas de régime
avec leur employeur est là comment ça va
ce fonctionné il faut dire qu'ils sont
assez nombreux 6 en plus de ses employés
il ya deux tiers en fête des
travailleurs ontariens qui n'ont pas de
régime de retraite très peu contribué au
reér donc ce qu'on fait en ontario c'est
qu'on va forcer l'employeur et l'employé
a déposé une cotisation alors ce que ça
veut dire par exemple on va offrir d'un
côté 1 9% pour les employés et pour les
employeurs ils vont devoir payer 1 9%
donc pour quelqu'un qui gagne environ
quarante cinq mille dollars par année ça
veut dire que chaque jour ils vont
déposer donc deux dollars 16 par jour
même chose du côté de l'employeur
tout ceci pour essayer de garantir une
prestation annuelle de 6400 dollars à
vie après 40 ans de vie active si vous
gagnez plus pas forcément vous cotisez
plus donc pour 90 mille dollars
là vous allez monter évidemment jusqu'à
12800 dollars donc hélas ça s'additionne
avec déjà la prestation du canada donc
ça veut dire 24 mille dollars c'est le
double de ce qu'on a au québec pour
l'instant ouais donc c'est beaucoup plus
avantageux de ce que face à sera pas
beaucoup plus avantageux que ce qu'on
offre ici me disais c'est ça parce qu'en
fait au québec on a décidé de choisir
une autre avenue c'est à dire que on a
créé le hervé
hier donc c'est le régime volontaire de
l'épargne-retraite donc pour vraiment
stimulé par une des québécois sauf qu'un
certain c'est valence et volontaire
alors que l'ontario c'est obligatoire
donc on verra sur le long terme qui a
choisi la meilleure solution est scellé
merci beaucoup frédéric